here's one just like we're doing this
morning okay and this is actually I'm 8h
so I'm doing some questions for you
ahead of time you're welcome
given this right they want to know some
conditions on G what values of G such
that and then they give you some some
properties of this quadratic so for
instance what if we know what if we know
so I'll say known that one root or one
of the zeros is on X is equal to zero
okay if you know that one of the roots
is equal to zero then I would say okay I
wanted to be in a relationship between
these coefficients and the roots right
well I will begin my question by saying
let the roots be alpha and I would
normally say beat up but I know that one
of the roots is zero right so I'm just
gonna make beta zero okay like so so now
I can say I should know what the summer
fruits is based on the coefficients and
I should know what the product of roots
is based on the coefficients right yeah
that's right okay so the summer fruits
the summer it's is just minus B on a
right - me on a maybe use cancel they go
you happy with that so that's just alpha
right down here the product of roots is
C on a I've got
okay so when you look at these right I
just started off with the summon product
because that's what I can calculate
fairly easily you can see that one of
these is more useful than the other and
for working out what the value of G is
can you see which one would you pick I
think I would pick this one right
because look at the first one after that
zero goes away you still have two
unknowns well I can't really go any
there there because I don't know what
else it is it could be anything right
but here because you multiply by zero no
and that's just the linear equation you
can solve that fairly easily
so out will pop your value for G okay
what's that gonna be - no - okay
yeah so there you go how much you do it
let's have a look at one like say no I'm
not gonna do that one under C C says are
known
what's known is
what if for the same quadratic the roots
are reciprocals of each other okay if
that's the data they give us then we can
assume let the roots be now rather than
say alpha and beta which is like who
knows what they are I know they're
reciprocals of each other so I can say
alpha and what's the reciprocal of alpha
one on alpha okay so now again I say
okay well what's the sum of the roots
alpha plus there's my second root one on
our fun that's still gonna be 3G minus
one or two right that's still the sum of
the roots there I haven't changed the
quadratic and the product alpha times 1
and alpha is still gonna be 2 G minus
five on two okay
now again you start to work out
depending on the conditions that get
given to you difference equations either
this one or this one or both will be
useful to do you think here again it's
the second one right that's just a
coincidence by the way it's because
reciprocals when you multiply them give
you something useful
Alfred zero when you multiply them give
you something useful later on if I said
for instance what if the roots were
opposite to each other
there'd be alpha and minus alpha then
multiplying lots are helpful but when
you add them you get zero so you get
something simple you can solve does that
make sense let's just quickly finish
this off you're going to get 1 equals 2
G 2 so 2 G minus 5 is gonna be equal to
2 so 2 G we equals 7 so G's 3 and a half
okay
so you can see like after you've
established this it just kind of becomes
a bit of numerical work right not
difficult this is kind of the hard step
so this here once you've got that laid
out you go into your son and product me
you think about what will be useful for
you